bally's is about to have a huge  transformation in the coming months  caesars entertainment made the big  announcement today multi-million dollar  project will include renovation of the  outside of the property new  entertainment and food options and a  complete redesign of the casino 4. when  it's all said and done it's going to  have a new name as well horseshoe  and it'll be modeled in the tradition of  the historic horseshoe casino so what is  the horseshoe and what are its ties to  las vegas well horseshoe has been under  the caesar's brand since the 1950s the  very first one owned by the binyan  family in downtown las vegas the company  also owned several other horseshoe  casinos in the midwest and on the east  coast caesars also announced that world  series of poker will be hosted at the  horseshoe as it comes to the strip for  the first time  the event has moved several times over  the years but at one time did play at  the original horseshoe in the 70s